a teenage boy is dead after a crash in  the northwest valley this happened near  sky canyon and iron mountain road  yesterday afternoon police say a  16-year-old boy riding a dirt bike ran a  red light that's when he was hit by an  suv he died on scene people living in  that area say racing has been a problem  not too long ago we had the street  takeover right here on this intersection  and it's just it's just a matter of time  and it's it's every day it's every day  it's awful it's really awful i don't  think there's enough security  cops i don't feel like there's enough  cop presence out here especially i don't  see it  metro police continue to investigate the  crash